Have you been thinking a lot about education lately? Because I have.
Yeah. So, I mean,
you've produced educational content that has been seen by tens of millions. Uh,
you know, you,
you developed a real knack for conveying concepts in a way that people find fun
and engaging. Uh,
and right now there's so many families and parents who are struggling because
their kids all got yanked out of school.
And we're all wondering what the heck is next. Um,
so it would love to hear what you're thinking.
I mean, can I ask you first, like, um, you know,
I think that you probably have a pretty unique perspective on education also on
education policy that I probably don't have. Um, and,
and I have a lot of fear about what secondary education or like what
post-secondary education looks like right now.
What do colleges and universities and community colleges look like? Um,
you know, if we find that we cannot gather in the same way and like,
how do we interface with, with that, with the problems that creates,
because of course education is like so fundamental to the foundation of like
all, all of it. Like all of society, all of innovation, all of like progress.
So post-secondary many colleges have no choice,
but to try and reopen in September because their finances are
constructed, such that if they were to not have a semester,
they would go bankrupt and go out of existence. That's true for many,
many schools, including some high end schools,
they're only a handful of schools that have these big endowments. Uh,
and even the schools with big endowments actually are operated in a way such
that it would be ruinous for them to not have a fall semester.
Now, the big question is how can you charge what you're charging if all of it's
online.
And a lot of kids are struggling with this right now where some kids who have
the choice, which is not many of them,
but are trying to defer because they're like, hell,
if I'm going to have my first year of college, be this online.
And I'd spent $60,000 for the privilege of attending class in my jammies and
whatnot like that, they're not into that, uh, which is understandable.
But from the, from the school's perspective, they're like the show must go on.
Like the school must open, uh,
and like many things with the Corona virus,
there have been problems building up in the system for decades where our
colleges have been doing a lesser and lesser job of actually educating people or
preparing them for modern day life where the economist.
Actually per dollar spent. Yeah.
Well, so here, here's the way the numbers work for the, for these colleges. Uh,
if you look at the cost of various things,
most consumer goods have remained relatively stable in price, um, books,
electronics, clothes, like you don't see the prices going up to the moon.
So what are the exceptions to that?
The two big ones are healthcare and education where healthcare just keeps
getting racked up and up and up, uh,
like higher prices to the moon in colleges every year. Like, Hey, guess what?
We're, you know, 4% more expensive. And then you compound that.
And college now costs two and a half times what it costs even then when I went
to college or when you went to school where like both in our forties and we were
probably not that far apart. So, so yeah. Um, so then you, you,
if you're a kid you're like, okay,
I guess college has 50 or $60,000 now in your family. Um,
and then does that mean that I get paid more on the way out? No,
it turns out opportunities completely stagnant. And I actually, if anything,
I've gotten rid of a lot of them. Um, so how the heck do I afford to go?
I take out massive government loans and the government's like, don't worry,
we've got you.
So now we're up to $1.6 trillion in school loans and families feel like, well,
I have no choice, but to take it out because it's college and, uh, you know, uh,
my kids got to go. The kid's like, well, clearly I'm going to college.
And so then they, they go, they get lit loaded up with this massive debt load.
And from the college's perspective, they've been paid.
They don't need to adjust particularly,
and they just keep ratcheting up the price every year. Um,
so if you dig deeper and you say, well, why is college so expensive?
Why is it that it has to go up in price? It's not professors,
it's not even facilities,
which most people would guess it's non-academic administrators.
The number of non-academic administrators in colleges have gone up 150% as
prices have gone up. They just keep on hiring more, uh,
administrators.
Yeah. And like a lot of it's like, uh,
like a lot of the money's being spent on sales basically like to like we're
spending money to make money. And that's just increasing. And like, if,
but if you don't, I was watching a friend of mine and go through this process,
her kids going to college. And like, she was like,
I got this huge booklet from this university in Alabama,
but the university of Montana, I live in Montana. So like the,
the local university, they only send us like a tiny little pamphlet.
And so I just don't feel like, and I'm like, no, don't go to the school.
That's spending all that money.
Like they sent you like a hundred dollars of material out of the blue
with, and like, you know,
chances are like 90% of those are not going to result in a sale or
more than that.
So like their customer acquisition cost is going to be astronomical.
And that's what you, as a student are paying for,
to acquire new customers for the university,
go to the school that isn't spending money.
Like it's spending money on teachers, not on, on sales, you know?
And so, so yeah, watching,
and you know,
people in academia have watched this happen and they've been, you know,
comfortable the whole time,
just watching as school has become closer and closer to not being worth
it.
And eventually you get to the point where it actually isn't worth it anymore.
And for a lot of majors, I think you're already there where it, unless you are,
unless you have a ton of money, you're not, uh, th like,
it's not going to be worth it for you to go to school.
It's not gonna be worth the loans. And like, it's, it's such a,
and it's, it's in the same way as healthcare.
It's like so depressing because this is like the one,
like one of the fields where it's like,
this is supposed to be all about helping people. And like,
it should be this like really great, good public,
good public service job,
but like more and more professors kind of can't feel that way because of how
much it costs.
Like you don't have to become professors, man.
Cause you have all of these PhDs who are in like the permanent postdoc,
adjunct hell,
where they're going to get paid a subsistence and there's no future.
And it's like, Hey yeah, tough luck. Like, uh, you know,
we just keep minting P PhDs and there are no jobs for you.
Yeah. And the, and, but, and that's,
what's keeping the level of like how much professors are, uh,
cost of university. That's what key that's, what's keeping it level.
Lots of professors, lots of tenured professors are making a ton of money,
but on average, it's,
hasn't increased because you've got all these adjuncts and you've got all these
people who are never going to get tenure and just like getting paid very,
you know, the basic, basic livings or not, not even a full living.
Teaching of students is not the primary expense that a lot of these places let's
put it that way.
They're not all exactly pouring the millions into making sure that,
you know, your kid has some world-renowned expert teaching them, uh, that it's,
it's really immoral. Uh,
what's gone on and it's in the guise of, like you said,
like a public good and a non-profit in some cases,
literally public institutions, uh,
we've really lost our way in so many,
in so many respects and education, healthcare,
I think are like the two that affect the most people that everyone can
understand that the third one is housing as the other source of inflation,
but it's not as extreme as healthcare and education in Mo and in some places it
is, but still a huge crisis. Yeah. It's,
it's not as extreme in like where you are in Montana.
Like there's certain Metro areas where it's it's as extreme or more extreme.
Yeah. Yeah. And you know,
what really frustrates me is I think that like, there's no doubt in my mind,
and I've always said this as somebody who sort of teaches, uh,
through the internet, I've always said that like,
there is no replacement for the classroom. And like,
that's not what we're trying to do with crash course.
We have no interest in that.
And I believe that that there's no replacement for the classroom,
except that like, now you have to know.
Now you're replacing the classroom. There's like no choice.
Cause that that kids.
Lost replaced. And so like, you have to adjust that statement to say like,
there's no system that is as good as the classroom, but there are other systems.
And if you're going to charge $60,000 a year for the classroom and other people
can find ways to charge $6,000 a year for an education without the
classroom, then you lose the classroom, which is the best way to teach people.
But you do lose it. Like you lost it anyway. And, uh,
because,
because we had to find a different way because it just costs too much money.
Yeah.
This is the crisis that many universities are struggling with right now.
And I think that they're going to be able to bear it for
one season. Um, no, a bunch of the marginal schools will close, even now.
It's like, just like, if you look around the country,
thousands of retailers are closing.
Thousands of theaters are closing tens or hundreds of thousands of restaurants
are closing. I'm sure hundreds of schools are closing. Uh, not,
not the big wealthier ones are the, the major public ones.
Um, they can stand it for one season. Um,
but depending upon how long this drags on for,
you're going to see more insolvent schools pretty quickly,
because a lot of families are going to look up and say, wait a minute,
like this makes absolutely no sense for us to be paying this kind of tuition.
Do you have a advice for kids who are graduating right now? I say kids,
but they're, you know,
I mean like getting like this was their last semester of college.
So like welcome to the job market. It's COVID.
Yeah. This is a very hard time to be looking for a job that is for sure.
Um, and so a lot of it would be around trying to find any
way in which you can contribute and develop that may or may not be in the field
that you were thinking of. It might not pay what you want.
The living situation might not be what you want. Uh,
but just as long as you're growing at all professionally,
uh, you should feel good about it. Like, don't think, Oh,
I really want to get into politics. So I have to like,
make sure it's like the perfect job in that space. Like, no, no. Just,
if you can find anyone that, um, will give you a chance to lend a hand,
just freaking go for it. And if that, and that's going to be hard to dislike,
given that it's easier said than done. Um, so it,
it would be about trying to find ways to make sure you are still developing
in some respect, even if you're trapped at home for like a while,
uh, you know, making schedules for yourself,
like setting goals for yourself that are achievable, uh,
reaching out to people when you don't feel like it,
because it's very easy to become somewhat of a shut-in I think during this time
for a lot of folks, uh,
but you have to continue to try and put yourself out there. Uh,
I don't have great advice. Uh, one of the things I will say though,
is that if you have time, like you're in better shape where like,
if you're a young person, you'll be able to, uh,
have this be like an early bump in the road,
but it's not going to define your whole journey.
Like the people I'm the most concerned about are folks where, you know,
they spent 10 years working on some, uh,
restaurant or bar food truck that now is like completely caput. You know, like,
like that, that stuff breaks my heart because I'm like you having, like,
I love entrepreneurs.
I love people who are actually trying to make something positive happen.
And this crisis is going to do a number on entrepreneurs to
a higher level than if you've got some corporate job that lets you work from
home.
Absolutely. Yeah. And it's,
it's so hard and so rewarding when it's working. Um,
but when it's not working, it is very hard to,
it's very hard to work through failure. Um, and like,
not just while it's happening, but afterward.
And I think that the important thing to know is like one,
hopefully everybody gets that, like, this is no one's fault. Well, I mean,
um, that like your failure was not your fault in this circumstance. Um, but,
and also that like, um, you know,
like one of the things, one of the really great things about making your own,
your own project,
investing in like taking your money and spending it on your dream,
instead of someone else's is how much you learn and you can take those
skills, other places and, you know, management, bookkeeping,
like entrepreneurs do everything. And so there, there is a lot, um,
like I think that they,
they are good hires and also there are other opportunities and other futures
and, uh,
there's going to be a lot of need for entrepreneurs and innovation as we find
new ways to operate. Um,
whether that's about coronavirus specifically,
or if it's just about the world continuing to change.
So we need people with those skillsets.
We need people with broad skill sets who are curious and passionate and want to
make.
Better. Thank you for listening in. I hope you enjoyed this conversation.
If you did, please do subscribe to yang,
speaks and click on notifications so we can let you know every time we have a
new episode.